hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar improving heterologous protein
production in yeast with massively
parallel crispr genome editing
i am kayleigh bach of labrutz and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by inscripta to learn more please
visit inscripta.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
please submit the questions below
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd now like to welcome our speaker eric
abate director analytical biochemistry
applications development at inscripta
eric you may now begin your presentation
thank you very much for that
introduction
today i'm going to give you an overview
of enscripta's onyx platform
and then i'm going to tell you about an
application where we've used the
platform in order to improve the
expression of a heterologously expressed
protein in yeast
so there are lots of challenges in the
synthetic biology and biological
engineering space so if you look at it
from say a forward engineering
standpoint where you're trying to
produce more of a product or produce it
faster
it really requires high dimensional
optimization and unfortunately we
usually don't know the rules of biology
so we have to determine the improvements
empirically
an example of this is production strain
engineering
in the reverse direction you have
something like genome discovery where
you're trying to understand how the
system works and trying to generate
knowledge about that particular system
and in that case you need to be able to
take the system apart in order to
re-engineer it for an intended purpose
an example of that is something like
antibiotic resistance or gene profiling
so the scale and diversity
pose a huge challenge
to engineering biology
and the current methods that are used in
order to introduce diversity
into an organism
excuse me are quite limited
so you might have things like gene
knockout or gene knockin
type of experiments
or things like classical mutagenesis
but the challenges with these current
methods is that they lack precision they
have slow and laborious workflows
there's a lack of diverse edit types so
a lot of these edits actually
are introduce loss of function mutations
and it's also difficult to separate
hitchhiker mutations from real causal
mutations for the phenotype that you're
looking for
so
on the the axis here on the left if
you're looking at on the y-axis say the
variety of edit types from low to high
the number of genomic locations
also from low to high
in this quadrant where you have simple
gene knockout or gnocchin experiments
you're introducing a very low
variety of edit types and you're
targeting a few genomic locations
something like protein engineering
where you're going to be introducing a
very high number of edit types but again
you're targeting a few number of genomic
locations
whereas something like genome-wide
knockout libraries or classical
mutagenesis
you're targeting a very large number of
genomic locations but the variety of
edit types are quite low
so what you really want to do
is to get up into this quadrant where
you're doing true genome engineering and
genome discovery where you're
introducing a wide variety of edit types
at many different genomic locations
and that's where i'd like to introduce
you to
enscripta's onyx platform or digital
engineering
genome engineering platform
and it allows you to generate precisely
engineer and barcoded libraries of cells
at your benchtop so i'm going to go
through some of the parts of the
platform
um next
so you could do rapid genome scale
engineering with the onyx platform and
the platform really supports all aspects
of the design generate test learn cycle
and it all starts with the encrypted
designer portal
and this is where a scientist can go in
and it's a simple graphical user
interface and design the edits they want
to introduce in an organism anywhere in
the genome
after you've designed your library
and place your order that initiates the
manufacturing of the reagents and
consumables that are necessary to build
that library
in about three weeks time the
reagents consumables arrive
you put them in the second part of the
platform which is uh the onyx instrument
itself so you put those rages
consumables into the instrument along
with the cells that you want to build
this library in
and you press go
and in a matter of days two to four days
depending on which organism you're
editing
out will pop this tube of edited cells
and this this engineered cell library
and within this tube of edited cells
each cell will have at most one of the
edits that you designed within your your
library within the designer software and
there could be thousands of different
edits and they'll talk a little bit
about the specs
later
on
inscriptive provides
kits that allow you to analyze that
that library that you built to see what
the quality of it is
and
then you can take that pool of edited
cells and immediately go into some sort
of
test
workflow and this could be a screening
type of workflow or it could be a
selection workflow as well
once you've identified your hits from
your screening workflow or you've
enriched in some population
in a selection workflow
escripta also provide kits that allow
you to extract the dna
from those samples and then submit them
for dna sequencing
that dna sequencing information then
gets imported into another software
package called the encrypted resolver
software
and this is what allows you to link the
genotype
of a hit to its particular phenotype
at this point you'll probably come up
with a bunch of other ideas that you
want to test or take a certain strain
through another round that can be
imported back into encrypted designer
software and you can go through this
cycle once again
so the um the platform provides
optimized designs it utilizes the mad 7
proprietary nuclease it has push button
simple workflow you can design libraries
anywhere from 100 to 10 000 designs per
library a single edit per cell a wide
diverse of edit types can be introduced
anywhere from 1 to 63 base pairs
and you could do rapid genotyping
through barcode and gs
and an important point here is that it
really democratizes genome editing and i
like to use myself as an example for
this because uh prior to coming to
inscripta i had never designed a library
and i certainly had never built a
library but i had phenotyped a library
but
by using the onyx platform i was able to
come up with an idea
design a library based on that concept
then once the reagents in came in
i could put them on the instrument with
the cells that i want to engineer and
press go and in a matter of days out
pops this tube of edited cells that i
can immediately go into a screening
workflow
so i was able to design
build and then go into test of that
library without help from anyone else
just interacting
with the software and the instrument
there's a wide diversity of edit types
that you can introduce into the genome
so this could target both the non-coding
region and the coding region so for the
non-coding region say in e coli you
might think of doing a promoter and rbs
insertion maybe a 61 base per insertion
and you could do this in front of every
single gene in e coli for yeast maybe
you want to do a terminator
substitutions you could take a synthetic
terminator and insert it or substitute
it at the three prime end of every gene
in yeast if you wanted to
[Music]
and then as far as the coding region one
of the things we
excuse me often like to do is uh
generate knockout libraries and we
typically do this by inserting a triple
stop codon at the beginning of the gene
or towards the beginning of the gene in
order to
to create a protein truncation
you can also do things like saturation
mutagenesis where you mutate every
residue within a protein to all 19 other
possible amino acids
and as far as some of the specifications
or more details about specifications for
the platform so currently we support e
coli and s cerevisiae
and this includes encrypt and script of
standard strains as well as related
customer strains
you can target the coding and the
non-coding regions in the native genome
or if you've introduced a heterologous
sequence
you can target that as well
i'll talk about an example of that
in the next section
as far as the designs per library e coli
is anywhere from one thousand to ten
thousand and for sarah vca it's a
hundred um
to six thousand
as far as precision currently there's
one edit per cell that you can do
you can do insertions you can do
deletions and you can do substitutions
anywhere between 1 and 63 base pairs
the library composition that comes out
of the instrument
is typically greater than 90 of the
designs are covered within um that that
tube of edited cells
and
anywhere between 15 to 75 percent of the
cells are edited
the time it takes reagent delivery is
about three weeks um and library build
takes anywhere from two to four days but
your hands on time with the actual
instrument is really less than an hour
to start a run
okay so now that i've introduced the
platform i want to tell you a little bit
about what you can do with it
and in this example we're going to try
to improve the production of a
heterologous protein in yeast
so protein production is important for
the bioeconomy
it has lots of applications in in the
industrial biotechnology space so there
are enzyme companies that produce
enzymes for
that can be used in the biofuels in
textiles food production or processing
animal feed household care like laundry
detergents
there's also applications in the
biopharma or therapeutic space where you
might target say a metabolic disorder
like diabetes using insulin
or in
cancer therapies as well
another like really hot topic right now
is the alternative protein market
where companies are trying to come up
with
non-animal sources of meat dairy or egg
proteins
so the current tools to improve protein
production
are actually quite limited right now and
i
used to work at an enzyme company where
this is one of the the some of the tools
that we use in order to improve the
expression
of a protein that we're interested in
so once common strategy is just to
insert extra copies of the gene into the
genome and this definitely can improve
expression but the improvements often
plateau once you insert many copies of
that gene
you can start to play around with the
expression cassette so maybe you want to
change the promoter very often use a
very strong promoter but maybe there's a
couple other ones that you might try or
you can change the terminator or you can
look at gene design you know such as
codon usage and codon optimizations you
might design a few different versions of
it and see which one expresses the best
or you could change the signal sequence
if the protein
is secreted
another common strategy is classical
mutagenesis of a production strain you
take your production strain you treat it
with a chemical mutagen introducing a
bunch of mutations throughout the genome
and certainly this can introduce
beneficial mutations but it can also
simultaneously introduce deleterious
mutations as well
and
it can also be complicated to identify
causal mutations
for improved production because you're
introducing so many different mutations
all at once
and
what we think is that the onyx platform
provides an attractive alternative way
of improving protein production
so in order to come up with a um a way
to test this we had to come up with a
model system and what we decided to do
was to try to improve
the expression of an enzyme called cbh1
so cbh1 is a is stands for
cellobiohydrolase one this is an enzyme
that's involved in the degradation of
cellulose and it releases cellular bios
from the reducing end of a cellulose
chain essentially it works as an
exocellus
so the cbh1 works in conjunction with a
lot of other enzymes in the efficient
degradation of crystalline cellulose so
you can see the cbh1 here working on the
reducing end
cleaving off solar bios subunits which
is just two glucose molecules linked
together
then an enzyme called beta glucosidase
takes the cellular bios and converts it
ultimately to glucose
why do we care about cbh1 well it turns
out it's important for an idea called
consolidated bioprocessing or cbp
and in a cvp process
the idea is that you have a single
strain
that
produces the enzymes that are necessary
for the degradation of some sort of
input feedstock very often it's some
sort of lignocellulosic waste plant
material
the enzymes degrade that feedstock
converting it ultimately to a sugar
which is then utilized by that same
strain
in order to produce some sort of fuel or
chemical so essentially all of these
enzyme productions such a hydrolysis and
fermentation are all consolidated in one
single reaction
so that's why we wanted to um one reason
why we wanted to try to improve
expression of the cbh1 enzyme
so the first thing we had to do was
excuse me to
generate the cbh1 expression strain
and develop an activity assay
so we decided to use a fungal cbh1 and
we did a codon optimization of that gene
for expression in yeast
we used the native
fungal signal sequence for that cbh1
the expression of the cbh1 is driven by
a yeast eno2 promoter and we utilize the
dit1 terminator
as far as the base stream we used it was
based on what it utilizes npk
e string
and we generated a single copy genomic
integration of the cbh1 expressions
cassette
into that strain
the assay is actually pretty simple and
straightforward so it utilizes a
synthetic substrate called pnp beta
lactopiranaside
and which is shown over here
so the cvh1 actually cleaves this bond
right here releasing paranitrophanol
and at elevated ph paranitrophanol
has a characteristic absorbance maximum
at 405 nanometers so we can just measure
cbh1 activity
at 405.
and we utilized this activity assay as a
proxy for active enzyme production
um
i should mention that there's no uh
detectable activity in the parent snpk
based stream
okay so the the screening workflow that
we used to test the various libraries
that we're going to build on this
production strain is pretty simple and
straightforward
so we took that tube of edited cells
that come out of the instrument we
played it on auger plates and then we
would pick colonies into 96 well mid
well plates and in a typical screening
workflow i would
pick between 10 to 20 plates
per library and these were picked into
300 microliters of ypd so a rich medium
was used for expression
these plates would be grown to
saturation
at for approximately 36 hours
at 30 c
then we would subculture those plates
into the production plates
which is essentially just fresh ypd
media
and then this production would go for 24
hours
so the saturated cultures were then
stored as glycerol stocks at minus 80.
so after 24 hours we would measure the
cvh1 activity in the supernatants from
for our primary screen
once we did that we would identify hits
those identified hits can then go into a
re-testing of them to confirm that
they're indeed hits we'd go back to our
glycerol stocks that we have
and go into a retesting
protocol which is essentially going
through the same process again
but this time they were tested in
quadruplicate
once we confirmed the hits
we would then genotype
so just to show you a little about the
noise within the screening workflow
we would pick um i picked 96 colonies of
the base expression strain
and then i would take it through this
entire screening workflow
um and then the the results of that
experiment is shown over here
so the average absorbance of 405
nanometers for those 96
samples
0.26 with a very low standard deviation
and a cv of 1.7 so that so the noise in
the screening workflow is is extremely
small so this really allowed us
to pick out hits with improved cbh1
expression
with very small improvements in cbh1
activity
okay so now we need to come out with
what type of libraries and what concepts
do we want to test to try to improve
cvh1 expression
and it kind of broke down into two
different categories so we had
genome-wide libraries
so this is basically targeting
everywhere in the genome
and then we had targeted libraries that
were targeting either the cbh1
expression cassette or targeting certain
genes that we thought might be important
for cbh1 expression
so for the genome-wide libraries
um we had genome-wide knockout libraries
where we inserted triple stop towards
the beginning of a gene and we did a
knockout library of every single gene in
yeast
and then we also made genome-wide
synthetic terminator insertion libraries
we took a synthetic terminator inserted
at the three-prime end of every gene in
yeast
and then we also had genome-wide
deletion libraries so in this particular
library there were deletions between 1
and 59 base pairs they were introduced
throughout the yeast genome
and these deletions could target either
promoter regions or it might target it
within the open reading frame of a
protein as well
then we have the on the targeted library
side
we had a couple different
variations that that we
designed
and several of them or a few of them
targeted the eno2 promoter itself by
targeting the predicted transcription
factor binding sites within the eno2
promoter and i'm going to talk about
some details of these libraries later on
we also made a cbh1 alternate codon
library that i'm calling which is
essentially a site saturation synonymous
mutation library
essentially what we were doing was we're
taking every codon in cbh1 and changing
it to all alternate codons that encode
for the same amino acid since we were
trying to do
codon optimization of the gene or see if
we could do further codon optimization
of the gene
then i have another library that i'm
calling the targeted knockout library
and for this library
i mined the literature
to try to find genes that have been
previously identified that when they're
knocked out they can improve the
expression of some heterologous proteins
so i threw all those into one library
i also did a genome-wide protease
deletion library where i knocked out
every protease
or targeted the knockout of every
protease in yeast
and then also targeted um the knockout
of some enzymes in the glycosylation
pathway which could have an impact on
the secretion of the cbh1
okay so these are the different library
concepts that we wanted to test
so what i'm showing here is the primary
screening of these libraries on
cbh1 expression
this is showing it as a box plot and on
the y-axis i have the full change over
the base string
and these are all the different concepts
that i just just just described
broken down into both the genome-wide
type of libraries as well as the
targeted
and in all of these cases all these
different libraries that we produced you
can see that there are many hits that we
identified that had a significantly
improved
expression of the cbh1 enzyme
so these hits were then taken into a
re-test workflow that i described where
they're tested in quadruplicate
and that's shown here
we identified hits ranging from a 1.1 x
to a 1.6 fold increase in cbh1 activity
i should mention this data that's shown
here in the bar graph
i'm showing the fold change over the
base string
and
the bars are showing the average and the
standard deviation of quadruplicates if
we identified a hit only once if we
identified the same hit multiple times
in a library then i averaged the full
improvement of those hits and i'm
showing the standard deviation of that
i somewhat arbitrarily picked
a hit as being anything greater than or
equal to a 1.1 x over the base strain
which is something that we could
reasonably pull out based on the very
low noise
within our screening workflow
and you could see that the two
strategies whether it's genome-wide or
targeted we were able to identify a
bunch of different hits from them
um some of them into the 1.65 1.5 fold
for nearly all of them
and
it was nice to see that even with the
cbh1 alternate codon library we were
able to pull out some really nice hits
from that
okay so one of the things i wanted to
talk about
at this point
is phenotyping strategies and what
really drives your phenotyping strategy
as far as how many plates should i
sample of these different libraries
and one of the concepts you need to talk
about is
phenotyping library coverage and this is
really the
the amount of your library that you're
able to screen when you
take through a certain number of
isolates through the workflow
so the phenotyping library coverage is
really dependent on several different
factors and it's the number of total
designs within your library
it's the edit fraction of your library
so not all of the cells that come out of
the instrument are going to contain an
edit
excuse me
um
so that editing fraction really um is is
important to determine your coverage
the distribution of the edits um within
your library
so this is also important because not
all edits are going to be equally
represented in your library and certain
edits might be over represented than
other ones
and then the other important factor is
the number of samples that are screened
and what this what these um
uh
factors allow you to determine is what
we're calling a screener score
so an example of that is shown over here
on the right and this is shown in the uh
the resolver software
in this particular example library it's
about a 5 000 member library
and the editing fraction was about 69
and what's shown here on the x-axis is
the number of isolates that are screened
and the percent of your library
that you're actually
covering during that screening workflow
so let's say we were going to screen
about 5100 isolates
with 69 editing you would end up
screening about 31 percent of the total
number of uh
input edits uh within your library so 31
of the 5 000 members would be screened
if you screen 51
100 isolates
it's important to note here that the the
slope of this curve isn't constant so at
low sampling the slope is quite
steep
whereas it's much more shallow when you
when you get to higher levels of
sampling and what that means is that as
you get to really high levels the the
more you go up in
the number of isolates you screen the
the marginal improvement gets smaller
and smaller as far as the number of
the library that you're
you're covering
so in this region you're getting a lot
of bang for your buck you're getting
much less bang for your buck once you
start get up into this region
so this concept went into generating
this
this table here
so what i'm showing is the library
concepts that were being screened
um and then the library size of each one
of those so in total there were about 15
000 edits that were designed
in an attempt to improve the expression
of the cbh1 between these seven
different libraries
then i'm also showing the number of
isolates from each one of these
libraries that is screened in total
there was about 8500 isolates
screened
i'm also showing the estimated library
coverage that was screened for these
different libraries so you can see some
of them have a fairly shallow sampling
so the large libraries you're screening
only about three percent to 13 percent
of the total diversity
whereas some of the smaller ones because
they're um screened at a higher level
you're you're getting um closer to the
maximum amount of the library that's
being screened
i'm also showing the number of retest
hits from each one of these libraries
and then also the number of unique hits
so if we some in
some instances we pulled out the same
hits multiple times from a library
and then i'm also showing the hit rate
here
and the hit rate can kind of give you an
idea of um how fruitful that particular
library is in identifying hits so with a
low hit rate of about 0.5 percent uh the
cbh1 alternate code on library even
though that's you know a somewhat low
hit rate we're still able to identify
hits from that
and one of the important points that i
wanted to bring up here is that shallow
screening of large libraries can
identify strains with improved phenotype
so you can see that even though i
screened the genome-wide knockout on the
terminator at only 13 or 3 percent
um i was still able to pull out a large
number of hits and a large number of
unique hits
providing a lot of diversity that can be
used for further library builds
and i think an important point that i
want to make as well
is that with limited phenotyping
capacity
it's better to shallow screen several
libraries than stream
uh a few very deeply
and the the idea behind this concept is
that each one of these libraries is
testing out a different strategy or a
different way of improving cbh1
expression
and it's far better to screen a lot of
different libraries at a shallow depth
with limited phenotype capacity than to
say screen a few of these concepts at
very deep depth because screening more
libraries allow you to explore
lots of different concepts and lots of
different diversity for improving the
expression of your heterologous protein
okay so if i wanted to look at um these
a lot of these hits that we identified
in these libraries
that target kind of the genome or the
basically the expression strain itself
um it was interesting to see that they
they fell into different categories
involved in different cellular processes
so i have it broken down in a stack bar
chart here by the different libraries
genome-wide knockout deletions across
genome the genome-wide terminator and
the targeted ko library
so we saw a lot of hits um targeting
proteins involved in the protein
degradation pathway several of them
involved in protein trafficking so it's
likely important for secretion
lots of them involved in
genes involved in stress response
involved in transcription or translation
nuclear transport glycosylation pathway
a few of them fell into this basically
in other categories some of them were
involved in metabolism
and then we also identified several hits
um that were that was interesting that
they were gene
of unknown function
um so this was kind of interesting that
we were able to pull out hits
in in this category because uh through
rational strategies of targeting certain
genes you would have never targeted a
gene of unknown function for improved
improving protein production
um so in in
doing an unbiased sort of genome-wide
type of strategy allows you to pull out
hits that you would have never
identified if you you had used a
rational strategy
so um looking at some of these hits that
we pulled out from these different
libraries it was interesting to see that
in some instances we're able to pull out
the same hit
or
an edit targeting the same gene in
different library strategies
so for instance this uvp8 gene
which was pulled out of the deletions
across genome library as well as the
targeted knockout library it's important
to note that these are actually two
different strategies so the targeted
knockout introduces a triple stop at the
beginning of the gene so
gene
basically approaching truncation
whereas in the case of uvp8 there was
about a 50 base pair deletion in the
middle of the open reading frame
and both of these libraries were able to
yield this ubpa gene and it was very
nice to see that the full improvement
um from this gene or edits targeting
this gene were very similar
the same was true for stm1
and then also
for someone as well from the genome-wide
knockout library as well as deletions
across the genome and it was very nice
to see that the fold improvement from
these were very very similar so this
really gave us you know nice confidence
in our screening workflow that we're
pulling out hits reproducibly from
multiple different libraries
and also
um the noise level in our screening
workflow because these libraries were
built at different times the screening
of these libraries was done on different
days at different times and yet we were
able to pull out the same hit
with a very similar fold improvement
okay now i wanted to talk about the
libraries that target the
eno2 promoter itself so the promoter
that's used to drive the cvh1 expression
and we wanted to see if that we could
use onyx libraries
to investigate the promoter architecture
so i'm showing um the cdh1
open reading frame here
as well as about 500 nucleotides of the
eno2 promoter
upstream of the cvh1 gene
um
and what we wanted to do in these
libraries was to target the predicted
transcription vector binding sites
located within the eno2 promoter
and we target these um binding sites
with designs um testing out a couple
different strategies
and that's what's shown here on the
bottom of the scrap are the different
design strategies
so the first design strategy was an
insertion
strategy where we take the native
transcription factor binding sites and
we add extra copies of them adjacent to
where the native ones are located
and that you can see the locations of
them right here targeting all these
different regions
then the next strategy was to delete
those binding sites individually and you
can see those are the different
deletions here in blue
then we also made um substitutions in it
or swaps and in that case we took a pool
of 109 transcription factor binding
sites and swapped them in at the native
um
binding sites within the eno2 promoter
so we're covering basically this whole
region
with edits
so on top of this black line is shown
the hits or the location of the hits
that were identified i'm going to zoom
in on the next slide in this region so
you can see it more closely but what i
wanted to point out was it was
interesting that we identif or we
targeted a lots of
binding sites within this region but we
didn't pull out any hits at all that
were in close proximity to the start of
the cbh1g
so if we zoom in on um
the location where we identified hits
um again we're showing the designs
down here in insertions deletions and
substitutions by the different colors
and then the hits are identified above
the line
so there are several different binding
sites located within this region of the
eno2 promoter so there's a few ash 1
binding sites mach3
fo2 hsf1 gcr1 and gal4 binding sites
if we looked at the hits that we
identified so kind of walk you through
some of these so at the mod 3 region if
we put in if we swap in an haa1
transcription factor binding site we
were able to see improvement of cbh1
i should mention if there's multiple
boxes that are at a location
that means that we pulled out different
types of hits
at that location
so this actual ash one binding site is
kind of interesting
in that we actually got hits from all
three different libraries at this
particular location so if you delete the
ash one binding site you improve cbh1
expression
if you substitute in
uh several different binding sites you
improve cbh1 expression or if you insert
a mock 3 binding site
right next to the ash1 binding site you
also see improvement of cbh1 expression
and what this suggested to us is that
this binding site might actually
function as a repressive site for cvh1
transcription
in that if you delete the binding site
swap in another binding site or put a
different binding site in very close
proximity
you're able to improve the expression of
cvh1
at fo2 we found a lot of different swaps
improved expression an insertion of fo2
an extra flow to site here some swaps
here at the ash one binding site or
insertion of gcr extra g001 sites at
this location could improve expression
as well so it basically got hits from
all three of these different concepts
and i think what's a nice point to
mention here is that
this is all happening in the context of
the genome itself so we're doing you
know promoter studies in the context of
the actual genome it's not on a plasmid
which might not be incorporated into
chromatin as it as normally would happen
in the genome so this might give you a
more accurate representative of
the
the changes to expression at the
promoter
okay so i kind of went through some of
the the small scale screening workflow
now we wanted to see well we identified
all these hits well did any of them
scale up to a larger um culture and we
tested them in 25 mil shake flasks
using ypd just as we did in
small scale and 20 grams per liter
glucose exactly the same conditions that
were used
so we took a series of hits from our
libraries so things coming from the
genome-wide knockout
you know two insertions or swaps and
then a cbh1 alternate codon library
and we grew them up in shake flasks
and i'm showing here the growth curves
from these experiments and because we
had larger cultures we could do
time courses
and i took samples at 9 hours 24 hours
48 hours and 72 hours after 48 hours
when i thought the glucose was probably
fully consumed i added an additional 4
grams for your glucose to see if i could
improve the expression of cbh1 further
so this is showing the absorbance at 600
nanometers versus time basically looking
at the different growth curves
and the base strain here which is shown
as a black dotted line
you can see it right here
it basically has
a normal growth curve several of the
hits um had very similar growth curves
but um it was also interesting to note
that many of the hits had
lower growth curves although not
significantly different but you could
see that it definitely grows
less well or grows to lower od
than the base strain
so a couple important points here is
the the the reason we saw improved cbh1
expression or cbh1 activity can't be
explained simply by you just have more
cells you know if these edits
cause the strains to grow better you
have more
cells producing more enzyme that can't
be the explanation
it was also interesting to note that
several of
the improved strains had lower growth
curves
than the parent strain or the base
stream
um and there's some evidence in the
literature that
they've people have seen this in hits
that they identified for improved
heterologous protein expression and the
thought is that some of the carbon
that's usually um going towards
more biomass production is being
diverted to improve protein production
so it's interesting that we saw that in
several of the hits here
now if we look at the actual cdh1
activity
for this time course again the base
strain is shown in here as a dotted
black line
and then all of the other strains here
and it was very nice to see that all of
the hits that we intested at large scale
um
are also hits
at large scale all the hits that we
identified in small scale also ended up
being large hits at hits in large scale
and you can actually look at some of the
growth profiles or the the production
profiles and see how it how it
compares to the base string
so some of them like for instance these
two right here they actually have very
similar profiles they just grow up or
they produce slightly higher levels of
cbh1
some of the other ones like for instance
these two right here they actually
produce very
at higher levels at the early time point
but then they level off kind of at a
middle range for cbh1 expression
and then you know this strain right here
which kind of produces in middle range
at the beginning it just levels off at a
much higher level of expression and the
addition of extra glucose impacted some
of these
for more cbh1 activity
where in in other instances it had no
impact but it was very nice to see that
all of these hits scaled up which gives
us again greater confidence in our high
high-throughput small-scale phenotyping
i also wanted to look at what is the
fold improvement that we get
in
flasks versus
plates and i picked this 24-hour time
point in order to do this calculation
because those are the time points that
were in common between the two scales
and what you could see from this data
looking at the percent improvement in
cbh1 activity
cbh1 expression
is that in some instances there's a very
similar fold improvement
in some instances you actually see a
much greater improvement in cvh1
activity so the largest hit here was an
84 percent improvement going from a 57
in small scale
and then some instances we saw a smaller
fold improvement but overall it was very
nice to see that
all the the fold improvements or the
improvements translate in larger scale
okay so now if we look at the type of
libraries and the cellular processes
that were targeted by these libraries or
the hits that we identified there were
some interesting things to know so we
have these genome-wide knockout and
deletion libraries targeting in the
genome we have genomic terminator
libraries
we had libraries targeting the eno2
promoter driving expression of cbh1 we
had alternate codon libraries of cbh1
protease knockouts and glycosylation
knockouts
the hits actually target lots of
different cellular processes so it hits
targeted transcription
whether it's sort of global
transcription or transcription from eno2
nuclear export
stress response so you might imagine
protein expression can cause a lot of
stress for a cell
translation protein degradation so we
saw lots of hits that regulate
proteasome function or just individual
protease knockouts or secretion
including glycosylation knockouts and i
think an interesting point to note here
is that all of these processes that
we're targeting or edits
that are targeting these different
processes all these processes are likely
important or what you might expect are
important for the expression of a
heterologous protein
and one of the exciting things i think
from this is that each one of these
pathways it likely has a bottleneck for
cbh1 expression
and it it gets me excited about what
happens when we start combining these
different edits into a single strain
where you're now alleviating multiple
bottlenecks
for a protein expression so hopefully
the combining of these edits into a
single strain will be the topic for a
future talk
okay so the last point i want to talk
about is the um the time
invested in in building these libraries
and going through this type of project
and that to try to prove to you that the
onyx platform really enables rapid
learning cycles
so the first thing we had to do was
generate and qc the cbh1 expression
string
then we used the designer software to
design the libraries
and then the the reagents were
manufactured
then you have to build the libraries
and then you have to phenotype and
genotype
those hits or the libraries and then
subsequently the hits
so that's going to be shown in the the
bottom of this
slide in the by these various different
colored
arrows
so i'm showing sort of a sample of a
project timeline for this project
and this is broken down into one month
increments
so the first part of the project was to
build this cbh1 expression strain which
after we got the um
we figured out which promoter we wanted
to use and terminator and all the
details of how to express this uh the
cbh1 it took about one and a half to two
months in order to build this now
obviously this timeline can be highly
variable
it could take longer than that or if
someone already has their production
strain or their expression strain then
there's no time
in order to produce that
then
to design and manufacture the seven
different libraries that were screened
it took about three weeks in order to do
that
once those reagents arrive you have to
start building those libraries and if
you have one instrument you have to
build those libraries serially
so in the case of
this particular strain of yeast
builds take anywhere from three to four
days
so i could build about two libraries
per week
once you build your libraries then you
can go into phenotyping
and the strategy that i used was that i
would phenotype two libraries or
initiate the phenotyping of two
libraries per week so after the first
week i would have two libraries built
and those two libraries would then go
into the phenotyping workflow
and the entire phenotyping and
genotyping of the hits took about one
month for each one of the libraries
but they could be done in parallel
so i would initiate the phenotyping of
these two libraries
and then during that same week i could
start building the next set of libraries
which could then go into phenotyping the
following week
so again you could build a library
serially but the phenotyping and
genotyping could happen in parallel
and ultimately it took about three
months in order to design
build
um and then phenotype and genotype uh
these libraries with this particular
strategy on mind
and in total the seven libraries were
screened and 74 unique hits were
identified
for improvement of cbh1 expression
i also want to
bring your attention to the resources
that were involved um in order to do
this project
so designing a library can take anywhere
from a half an hour to a few hours per
library
the build uh the amount of time you have
to actually interact with the instrument
putting the reagents in your cells on
it's really only a few hours so maybe
two to three hours
per week is spent on that
and then as far as phenotyping and
genotyping
i i estimate it's about a quarter
of an employee
to do this particular workflow so not a
huge amount it's actually a fairly small
amount of resources in order to identify
all of these hits um in this small
period of time
okay so as far as conclusions um kind of
take home messages
are
the onyx platform is really a game
changer for dgtl cycles so it allows you
to rapidly design and build genome
edited libraries using significantly
less resources and it really
democratizes genome editing again i use
myself as an example for the cbh1
project i was able to come up with a
concept design that library build that
library and phenotype it all on my own
without anyone else's
help
i also want to make a point that
genome-wide or untargeted libraries and
targeted or rational libraries can both
identify strains with improved protein
production so we found both of those
strategies as being very fruitful
targeting the expression cassette or
doing rational knockouts as well as
untargeted and unbiased genome-wide
libraries
and also that shallow screening of large
libraries can yield beneficial diversity
in that phenotyping a wide variety of
library concepts is likely better than
deeply screening
a few libraries particularly when you in
the next step when you want to start
combining those since they're um
targeting you know potentially different
bottlenecks within
the protein production pathway
once you start combining those you might
be alleviating multiple bottlenecks and
be able to
obtain strains with significantly
improved
expression
and with that i'd like to thank you for
your time and i'd be happy to take any
questions that you might have
thank you eric for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
okay let's get started
our first question asks
can you upload an in
excuse me can you upload an inscript
designer your genome of interest would
the edit protocol work with organisms or
cells other than
escara asharakiya and saccharomyces
excuse me for the pronunciation
yeah good question so indeed um you can
upload uh whatever genome that you're
interested in or your genome
into the
designer software
the the key there though so you can
upload it and then you can design edits
against that the key is that uh
currently we're only supporting e coli
and um srbca
for that process so you can't just use
whatever cells you want to use um it has
to be a strain that's similar to one of
in scripture's standard strain and there
are kits that we provide that allow you
to actually test the editing process in
your particular string but currently um
e coli and cerebesia are are the two
hosts that we're currently supporting
great thank you our next question asks
genotyping is by sequencing amplicons
yes so there's a couple different
strategies you can you can use you can
either sequence the barcode to identify
um the edits that are contained within
that hit
um or you could do uh whole genome
sequencing so we've used both strategies
um in identifying hits
so both of those are are possible
great thank you
all right next question here your normal
application here is cbp which looks
nothing like mtp or shake flask growth
which library designs are likely to
yield hits that are productive in
application more broadly how important
is it to screen in application relevant
conditions
yeah for sure that i mean that's a very
important point
and you know this is kind of a
scaled-down version of a cbp you know
type process
in that we're really trying to improve
the expression of one enzyme that would
be involved in cbp this is something
that you you if you're actually looking
for um you know
a real uh cbp type hit you would want to
doing this in a in a more complex system
where you're expressing many um other
enzymes this is kind of a simple
simplified case that allows us to you
know use it as a test case um certainly
you would want to
screen as close to application
conditions as you possibly can get i
mean this is something that you know is
very common um that microtiter plate or
small scale
experiments you need to make sure that
those hits go to more application
relevant type processes so that's
something that you have to do um and and
in this case you know we're not actually
trying to build a cbp um strain um we're
just trying to to to show this is an
example of a way to improve um the
expression of an enzyme but that's
that's definitely an important point is
that you want to screen in conditions
that are are most relevant um for your
application or for scale up
wonderful thank you we've got lots of
great questions coming in here the next
one asks is deep screening ever
warranted does the hit analysis tell
when it's worth sampling deeper
yeah so that's that's kind of an
interesting question um
and you know the shallow screening
strategy i can't i think kind of really
depends on what you're trying to get out
of your library right so there might be
an example where you have say a really
targeted library so we have this
targeted knockout library that we wanted
to study and maybe in that case you're
really trying to answer the question of
do these hits have any impact and in
that case you might actually want to
screen quite deeply to make sure that
you've you know assessed all of those
hits and whether or not they they impact
the phenotype that you're looking for
um and then it also depends probably on
um the
the amount of hits that you get out so
if you're able to shallow screen say a
large library and you get a large number
of hits then maybe you're happy with
that number of hits um because kind of
one of the keys that you have to to
think about is you want to identify hits
as fast as you can
which usually yields some level of
improvement but the large level
improvement really comes when you start
combining those
hits into one strain
and this has been seen in you know
protein engineering type of experiments
as well as in strain engineering we have
a nice example of this with lysine
production
where we saw the really large
improvements when we started to combine
those hits
so i think it comes down to something
where what is the phenotyping capacity
you have that's available
how many hits you're identifying
and how fast you want to move because
maybe you just want to identify some
number of hits and then just really
start combining those so it's a good
question and it really depends on what
strategy you're
you're trying to address or your
strategy your phenotyping capacity your
your the speed that you want to work
there's lots of factors that kind of go
into that
decision
good question
great all right next question here how
does the pipeline change for an
adaptively evolved e coli or s
cerevisiae strain
yes so i'm not exactly sure what
they're trying to ask i assume they mean
if you have a strain that you've done
ale
type of work on how does the process
change
and if that's the question that's being
asked so usually you have to do some
sort of genome sequencing of that strain
um so that you can upload that into the
encrypted designer um platform or the i
or encrypted engineering platform so
that you can more accurately design the
edits
against that that strain so ideally you
want to have good sequencing information
i think that that's that's really
critical
all right our next question here says
you haven't had or you haven't yet had a
chance to build the combinatorial
libraries do you have an example of how
high an expression target could be
improvised based on the addition of
positives from several areas of
um
physiology
what would be a reasonable guess as to
how high the activity could go as a
result of combinatorial effort
yeah so that's a difficult um
thing to assess um right now in in this
uh situation i mean we do have examples
in this previous um
application i mentioned we were trying
to overproduce lysine in e coli and we
got a lot of different hits throughout
the genome whether it's targeting the
lysine biosynthetic pathway
or um just genome-wide things that are
targeting basically the genome
everywhere
and what we found in that case was that
we didn't start seeing really large
amounts of improvement until we started
combining them and the greatest
improvement we saw was about a 14 000
fold improvement when we had three
different edits that were combined
within that that strain now that's for a
small molecule so i think that that's
likely not what you're going to see with
the protein production you're not going
to see a 14 000 fold improvement it's
unlikely
um
but i think it's difficult at this point
to really say because um you know we're
starting with probably a very
unoptimized system we're using a wild
type you know
yeast strain that we've inserted a gene
um so not heavily optimized so my
prediction is that when you start
combining those that you're going to get
a much larger level of improvement but
it's hard to say at this point
great thank you looks like we have time
for a few more questions here this next
one asks what is the advantage of using
the inscriptive platform for genome-wide
knockouts over
for example transposon mutagenesis
yeah so um
for transposon mutagenesis uh i believe
those can be targeted i'm not sure that
they can actually be no specifically
targeted they might be able to but i
think um one of the advantages of i
think the inscriptor platform
is that you can specifically target it
um to a location and it doesn't even
have to be to a specific gene you can
target it anywhere um within that gene
um because you have the you know the
opportunity to target so many places
with the gene and you using crispr you
can really engineer the location of
where
that cut's going to be introduced so i
think one of the advantages of this
platform of it is it's really targeted
and then it's also a trackable system so
you can have a barcode that allows you
to very rapidly genotype and track those
edits that are being introduced
great thank you and we have time for one
more question here
can onyx generate random multiple genome
edits in one cell simultaneously
yeah so random um genome edits uh can't
really be introduced i mean it's all
targeted right so
i i guess you would say that's not
necessarily random
um and currently the platform um allows
for the introduction of a single edit at
a time but i will say that we're working
on expanding the platform to be able to
introduce multiple edits at the same
time and in that case you can do maybe
combinatorial type of libraries where
you can have different registers that
allow you to introduce a combination of
different edits simultaneously which
allows you to build you know larger
combinatorial type space or allows you
to sample larger combinatorial space
much greater than a single edit
would be able to introduce
all right well thank you again eric for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor in scripta for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it is available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye